The news we received of the death of
our Sheikh, the learned scholar and mujahid Rabi' ibn Hadi al-
Madkhali,
may
God Almighty have mercy on him, was announced by Sheikh Khalid al-Dhafiri, may God Almighty bless him and grant him peace. He
was a mujahid
in clarifying the truth,
spreading the Sunnah, and
refuting those who opposed him.
I am a sheikh of Sheikh Rabi', may God Almighty have mercy on him, a mujahid of God, may
God bless him and grant him peace. There is no follower of the Sunnah in this era who does not owe a debt of gratitude to the Sheikh, after the grace of God Almighty.
This is evident through his books, writings, and
his struggle in refuting the groups of misguidance.
During his time, may God have mercy on him, misguided
parties and deviant sects were widespread.
He struggled against them alone, with few supporters, and he demolished the idols of
their leaders and their sanctified figures,
such as Sayyid Qutb, clarifying his misguidance,
deviation, and the danger of his
methodology
to Muslims. I
lived with our Sheikh, may God have mercy on him, for many years.
I received knowledge and other things from him, as did others.  Some of my brothers are
students of knowledge who studied under him and witnessed the remarkable
qualities of the Sheikh, including his knowledge, asceticism, truthfulness, and sincere advice. They were
amazed
by his character and attributes,
from his honesty and sincere advice
to other qualities, may
God have mercy on him.
I wrote a large book about him,
more than 400 pages long, titled "The
Shining Chapters
of the Biography of Sheikh Rabi' ibn Hadi 'Umayr al-Madkhali and His
Scholarly and Da'wah Efforts." The
previous chapters are titled "The Sign of
Sheikh Rabi', may God have mercy on him." I wrote this about six years ago, and it will be translated into English, God willing. Perhaps we will take a look at his life and some of his biography. Our Sheikh, Rabi',
is named Rabi' ibn Hadi ibn Muhammad ibn Rabi',
from the 'Umayr tribe.
Some specialists mention that this tribe traces its lineage back
to the Na'amiyah tribe, the noble Sayyids, and their lineage
reaches back to al-Hasan ibn 'Ali, may God be pleased with
them both. However, they
entered into an alliance with the well-known Madkhali tribe.  The people of Al-
Janoub
are a well-known tribe from Qahtan in the south of the Kingdom. The
Sheikh, may God preserve him, has a large family and
ten sons, all of whom I know to be people of goodness, virtue, generosity, good character, and piety. The
Sheikh, may God have mercy on him, was
born in a village called Al-Jaradiyah,
which is connected to the city of Samtah in Jizan.
Our Sheikh told me that he was born in the year 513 AH (
1351 CE), the year of
Sheikh Rabi', may God have mercy on him. It is also said that he was born
before that, because determining birth dates
in the past was
not reliable.
Therefore, he may or may not have passed away at the age of approximately
96.
God Almighty said, and the
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said, "The best of you is he whose
life is long and whose deeds are good." His deeds were long, and we believe and
testify that they were good. We believe this to be true. He was raised as an orphan by his mother, may
God have mercy on her, and
under the supervision of his uncle Ibrahim,
as his father passed away when he was young, around two years old. She raised him in the
best possible way, may God have mercy on her. The
Sheikh was known from a young age for his eagerness to seek
knowledge, his brilliance, and his diligence
in the Sunnah.  At the age of eight, he enrolled in
what is known as a kuttab (traditional Quranic school) and studied calligraphy, the Quran, and
recitation. He
also learned from his teacher, Sheikh Abdullah al-
Qarawi, may God have mercy on him. Sheikh al-
Qarawi played a significant role in spreading monotheism in the south of the Kingdom. Sheikh al-Qarawi, may God have mercy on him, was the
teacher of Sheikh Ahmad al-
Najmi and Sheikh Hafiz al-Hakami. Sheikh al-Qarawi, may
God have mercy on him, was the teacher of Sheikh Ahmad al-Najmi, who in turn was the teacher of Sheikh Rabi'. He told me that he wrote for him the beginning of the Three Fundamental Principles. Sheikh Rabi', may God have mercy on him,
taught him some aspects of monotheism, the hadith of Bulugh al-Maram, and some aspects of
inheritance law. He also enrolled in the Salafiyya school, which also played a role in spreading the Sunnah and monotheism in the south of the Kingdom. The reputation of this school spread, and a number of students enrolled to study hadith, the Quran, and other subjects. He also enrolled in the Scientific Institute in Samtah, whose director was Sheikh Hafiz, may God have mercy on him, the teacher of Hafiz al-Hakami, may God have mercy on him. He
studied there for about five years and
learned from Sheikh Hafiz at this
institute. The Sheikh
loved him very much.  Hafiz
also loved Sheikh Rabi'ah very much.
Hafiz
Rabi' Hafiz studied with him the forms of jurisprudence, terminology, and
other sciences, including the
principles of jurisprudence and the terminology of hadith.
He also studied with his brother, Sheikh Muhammad al-Hakami.
I also met Sheikh Muhammad in the south.
He also studied at this institute with Sheikh Ahmad al-
Najmi, may God have mercy on him. Sheikh Ahmad,
may God have mercy on him,
loved Sheikh Rabi' very much and always praised him.
Also among those who studied with him at this institute was
our Sheikh, the scholar Muhammad
Aman al-Jami, may God have mercy on him.
Our Sheikh used to say, "I never tasted the sweetness of the creed in the Oneness of God's
Names and Attributes except at the hands of this
man, Sheikh Muhammad Aman al-Jami, may
God have mercy on him."
Our Sheikh did not only study formally,
but he diligently read
and studied on his own, as is the case with a student of knowledge.
Then, after that, he joined Imam University in Riyadh,
College of Sharia,
in the year 1381 AH (1961 CE).
He studied there for three months. Then the
Islamic University in Madinah,
Imam University in Riyadh, opened.  During
those months,
Sheikh Abdul Aziz bin Baz, may
God have mercy on him, was also present.
Then, when the Islamic University opened, the
students were given the option to transfer. Our Sheikh entered
Medina with a group of students and
studied at the university for several years. A
number of scholars taught there,
including Sheikh Abdul Aziz
Baz, from whom he studied a portion of Al-Tahawiyyah, may
God have mercy on him. Sheikh Abdul Aziz Baz
later became the university's director. Among those who
taught him was Sheikh Abdul Muhsin Al-
Abbad, may God
preserve him.
Also among those who taught him, loved him, supported him, and
defended him was the eminent scholar Muhammad Nasir al-Din al-
Albani, may God have mercy on him. He
also studied Tafsir and Usul al-Fiqh
for four years, including the renowned commentator and
Imam Muhammad al-Amin al-Shamti, may God have mercy on him. Another of
his teachers was the eminent
scholar Hammad al-Ansari, may God have mercy on him.
Hammad al-Ansari
gave him the book "Al-Madkhal ila al-Sahih" and asked
him to verify it.
Likewise, among
those who loved and praised him was a sheikh named Saleh al-
Iraqi, may God have mercy on him. The sheikh used to praise him and his
strictness in adhering to the Sunnah and Tawhid. Al-Iraqi was
also one of his sheikhs
outside the university, Sheikh Hamoud al-Tuwaijri, may
God have mercy on him. He received an ijaza (license to teach)
from him and praised him greatly.
Hamoud, may
God have mercy on him, also
met a group of scholars, may God have
mercy on him, such as Sheikh Khalil Harras, as well as Abdul Rahman al-Muallimi and others. Then, after graduating, he studied at the Scientific Institute, may God have mercy on him, for a period. Then, His Eminence Sheikh Abdul Aziz bin Baz sent him
to India, where he
stayed for three years. He had an impact, may God have mercy on him,
on spreading Tawhid and
combating some of the innovations that existed among the scholars of
Hadith, may God have mercy on him.
Rabi, may God have mercy on him,
received ijazas from scholars of Hadith. He
also had a
role in contributing articles to
their magazine, Al-
Jami’ah al-Salafiyyah, in Pensek.
I obtained these articles and
mentioned them in this book.
Then, he returned from India and enrolled in postgraduate studies
in the Sunnah Department at King Abdul Aziz University
in Mecca.
Yes, King Abdul Aziz University in Jeddah,
Mecca, Mecca had a branch in Mecca.  Yes.
Then after that, he wrote his master’s thesis,
which was
between the two imams,
Muslimah and Darqutni, and it is one of the most valuable thesises on
this subject.
Imam Muslimqani,
as well as his doctoral dissertation
on the critical edition of
Ibn al-Salah's book, "Al-Nukat 'ala Ibn Hajar al-
Salah,"
continued his scholarship, teaching,
research, and
supervision of dissertations until his retirement in
1418 AH (1997/1998 CE).
Among his earliest books and writings was "Manhaj al-
Anbiya' fi al-Da'wah ila Allah fi al-Hikmah wa al-'Aql" (The Prophets' Methodology in Calling to God with
Wisdom and Reason).
This book had an impact in refuting the
Ikhwani ideology and its extremism regarding governance.
As for his travels and efforts in calling to God, the
Sheikh traveled to a number of countries,
calling to God and teaching about
God Almighty. One
of his earliest journeys was for Hajj with Sheikh al-
Qar'awi, may God have mercy on him.
During his university studies, he
also undertook da'wah trips and
other journeys to various countries. As mentioned, he traveled
to India and stayed there for an extended period. He
also traveled to Egypt in search of manuscripts and to Yemen, again for da'wah purposes. He
also traveled to Bangladesh, where he stayed for two
full months and conducted several
courses. He
also made numerous other trips to India,
Pakistan, Afghanistan, and
Kuwait twice.  I was with him on that
trip, and
he also traveled to Sudan to spread the word of God
Almighty. Sheikh Muhammad Abdul Wahhab al-Banna, may God have mercy on him, was with him. He
also passed through some
African countries, such as Kenya. He had an impact on the
conversion of two Christian families in that
country. The
Sheikh saw them and thought, "Perhaps we can advise them." So he began asking them, "Who
created the heavens? Who created the earth? Who created?" They would answer, and
then the translator suddenly expressed his joy and
said, "They want to enter Islam." The
Sheikh was afraid that if he returned to their families, they might change their minds.
When they returned the next day, they said, "Sheikh, all our family
has entered Islam, and
we want you to give us names, me and my friend." He said, "You are
Abdullah, and this is Abdul Rahman. As for the children, you can
name them
Abdul Rahman." He also traveled to
Morocco and Tunisia
to search for a number of manuscripts. He played a
role in collecting many manuscripts of Sahih
Muslim. He
also had trips within the Kingdom. He
went to Najran, and I was with him on that trip.
He also traveled to Hafr al-Batin.
As for his trips to Taif, Jeddah, and Riyadh to meet with
scholars, these are numerous.  He had a
strong and good relationship with His Eminence Sheikh
Abdul Aziz bin Baz, Saleh Al-Fawzan, Haydan,
and Sheikh Ibn Uthaymeen, may
God have mercy on him. He
loved Sheikh Al-Albani, his teacher, may God have mercy on him, and
defended him greatly.
He traveled to Unaizah to meet Sheikh Ibn
Uthaymeen and gave a series of lectures there. I was with him
on that trip, may God have mercy on him. There was a
meeting after the Isha prayer, and
Sheikh Ibn Uthaymeen had a lesson after
Isha, so he canceled it to attend and greet
Sheikh Ibn
Uthaymeen, may
God have mercy on him. Among
his important words was when Sheikh Ibn
Uthaymeen arrived, he said, "We
thank God that He facilitated for our brother, Dr.
Rabi', to visit this region, may
God
Almighty have mercy on him,
so that those who are unaware of certain matters may know that
our brother, may God grant him success, is on the path of Salafism, the way of the Salaf."
Then he mentioned that his visit, especially to Unaizah,
would have an impact in clarifying what was  Hidden from the
people,
he points to the influence of the partisans there in distorting the image of the
preachers and scholars of the Sunnah. He
said, "So that many people may see what was hidden
through Judaization, promotion, and unleashing the tongue of
falsehood against the scholars. And how many are
those who regret what they said about the
scholars
when it becomes clear to them that they were on the wrong path."
Then one of those present asked him, "I am present and listening." They
said, "There is a question here about the books of Sheikh Rabi'."
He said, "This question is unnecessary,
just as Imam Ahmad was asked about Ishaq ibn Rahwayh al-
Qanawi, and he said, 'Someone
like me is asked about Ishaq?
Ishaq is asked about me.'" He said, "And I
spoke at the beginning of my speech about what
I know about Sheikh Rabi'."
He said, "His coming here and the speech he
delivered undoubtedly increase our love for him."
As we mentioned, the Sheikh studied and resided in Medina for a long time,
then after that he
lived in Mecca in al-Awali for a long time,
then he returned to Medina and remained there for years
until God took him.
Sheikh Rabi', may
God have mercy on him. And
among the supplications of the Sheikh, which I heard often
from him, may God have mercy on him, was that he used to pray to be granted a place of residence in Mecca,
meaning to live in Mecca.  He was granted permission to
die in Medina. God Almighty answered
his prayer, and he died in Medina and
was buried in Al-Baqi' with the companions of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him.
Sheikh Manshan, may God preserve him, Sheikh Rabi', may
God have mercy on him, made a
supplication to
God Almighty, may
God Almighty bless him and grant him peace. The
Sheikh had
numerous scholarly lessons
with his students in mosques, and all of this
refutes their claim that the Sheikh only had
refutations.
We studied with him during our time in Medina. He taught the
Tafsir of Ibn Kathir, the Hadith scholar, and the Sahih of
Imam Muslim, which he loved very much. My
Sheikh,
Ibn Kathir, was
also a scholar of Imam Muslim. He also taught in Mecca, where he resided, in the
mosque of Sheikh Baz. Sheikh Baz, may God have mercy on him, gave him permission to
teach before his death, may God have mercy on him. He taught Rabi', and
he taught Fath al-Majid, Al-Ba'th al-Hafith, and other
books. He taught Fath al-Majid, Hadith,
Ibn Kathir, and Al-Habib Ibn Kathir, may God have mercy on him.
As for the Sheikh's character and
attributes, he was distinguished, may
God have mercy on him, by his good character and distance from bad
character. I
witnessed this and lived with him for many years, and others witnessed it and
learned it from him, including his sons, family,
students, and
even his teachers.  His peers testify to this: he
combined humility,
truthfulness, and generosity. He
loved students of knowledge and those who visited him, honoring and hosting them. He
opened his heart, his home, and his wealth to them. His
table was rarely empty of guests, and he rarely
ate alone. May God have mercy on him.
Despite his intense concern for advising
Muslims and people in general, enjoining good and forbidding
evil, he would
not remain silent or patient when wrongdoing occurred. He was eager for the
truth, guiding people, and
bringing them back to the correct path—the Salafi path, the path of the Companions, the way
to deliver
people from the misguidance and darkness of polytheism, innovation, and
deviation. There is no group of innovation, deviation,
or disbelief that the Sheikh did not address in
clarifying its error and deviation. He wrote refutations of
Christians and
Jews, refutations of the
Rafidites and the
Mu'attilah, and others. He also wrote refutations of the laxists, the
Sururiyyah, the Qutbiyyah, the Tablighi Jamaat, and
others. Whoever
deviated while claiming to follow the Sunnah, he would advise them, explain the truth to them, and be patient with them.
If they did not return, he would refute them and clarify their error.
Among his noble character traits...  I spoke about him in this book
because, may God have mercy on him, he was
truthful in his speech, loved truthfulness, and hated lying and
liars. He used to
say that a
truthful Salafi should strive for truthfulness and avoid lying. In fact, he used to say, "
Lying is more despicable
to the Sunnis
than an innovator."
Therefore, if we know that he loved truthfulness and hated
lying, how can we then describe him as a fabricator
and forger when he responds to those who disagree with him? He
was
telling the truth
about the people of whims and innovations. He doesn't fabricate. He
once told me
that 15 men from the Khasib tribe came to him. They had
agreed among themselves to
take his responses to Sayyid Qutb and use them to refute
Sheikh Rabi'. They were
listening and thinking
that the Sheikh was fabricating against Sayyid, that he was omitting his words, that he was
cutting his words, and so on. So we began to
compare what you quoted from Sayyid Qutb
from his books, going back to the original source, and we found that you were quoting his words word for word, down to
the commas. We
knew that
you were on the right path.
We ask you, Al-Hallah,
to forgive us.
Our Sheikh said in one of his responses to Al-Falihi, “
Rabee’ does not fabricate lies against anyone,
whether from the Sunnis, the innovators,
or even the disbelievers. Rather,
he strives for truth and justice to the best of his ability.”
Among his noble qualities, may God have mercy on him, was his profound humility. He
detested arrogance and the arrogant. His humility, may
God have mercy on him, was evident in his open-mindedness.
If someone came to him and noticed something wrong or an error in his writings, he would readily
accept it. He even
wrote an article on this, stating that accepting advice
and submitting to the truth are among the greatest obligations upon
all Muslims. There are
many examples of this in his words and actions, may
God have mercy on him. He
said, “I seek refuge in God from rejecting advice
or defending an error or falsehood that has come from me.”
Whoever saw and lived with our Sheikh
knew his humility, his asceticism, and his distance from worldly
comforts.
They knew that this man placed the world beneath his feet
and kept the Hereafter before his eyes.
When he spoke of himself, he belittled himself and called for
humility. He never loved praise.  People
praised him, and he said to one of those
who gave him a lecture, "
What did the scholar say to him?" He replied, "
I am a student of knowledge, not a scholar, nor a professor, but a student of
knowledge." He
said that he acquired this manners from his sheikhs, and he
even disliked the
doctor if he had acquired them, may God have mercy on him.
As for his eagerness to enjoin good and forbid
evil, whenever he
saw something wrong, even in the Haram (the Sacred Mosque in Mecca), whether it was in
clothing or anything else, he would strive to denounce it and not leave it. His denunciation of wrongdoing included
his refutations of the people of innovation and his denunciation of their misguidance and deviation.
Our sheikh did not fall short in this aspect and
relieved many scholars of this obligation by dedicating his
effort and time to protecting this religion and
purifying it from the sayings and opinions of the people of disbelief, atheists, and
innovators. He was a
pioneer in refuting
and exposing the advocates of takfir (declaring others as infidels), Sayyid Qutb, and the
Muslim Brotherhood. This was
at a time when propaganda was intensifying, and the Brotherhood had a reputation for being
supporters of Islam and martyrs. This is why they hated him so intensely,
to the point that they praised God for...  His death, may
God Almighty be glorified and exalted, and these people want to extinguish the light of God with their own hands, but
God will perfect His light. May God Almighty hasten his death.
All his responses are from the perspective of advice and are based on
justice and the avoidance of injustice.
Therefore, among his sayings, may God have mercy on him, is: “From
my youth and the beginning of my scholarly life, I called people to
adhere to the fundamentals and branches of the religion, may
God Almighty be glorified and exalted. I warned against forbidden and disliked things. I denounced innovations, both major and minor, as
advice for God, His Book, His Messenger, the leaders of
the believers, and the general public, may God Almighty be glorified and exalted. I befriend and oppose based
on this.
This is my approach and methodology in my writings, articles, lessons, and activities.” Among his noble character traits, may
God have mercy on him, is that we have spoken
extensively about his responses to those who disagreed with him.
Among his noble character traits, may God have mercy on him, which the
people of innovation deny and
criticize our Sheikh for, is that he lacks patience with those who disagree and is
hasty in responding, as Mashhour Hassan
Salman said in his last audio recording after his death.
Yes,
this is a misconception that the Sheikh lacks patience and restraint. Rather, the
Sheikh is among the most patient of people with those who disagree with
him.
He advises them and repeats the advice so that perhaps they will return.
They repent, but they are not among the deviants and innovators. Those who deviate will be
punished by the whips of truth and the writings of our Sheikh.
This also shows us that if the Sheikh is patient
even with those who disagree, how can we not be patient with our
Salafi brothers?
This is what our Sheikh advised in his will: patience with the
Salafis, unity, and avoiding slander. He used to
say, among his sayings, that we should be patient with the Salafis, we should treat them. He said, "We have nothing to
lose. We should open hospitals to treat them." He used to say,
metaphorically, "We treat them with advice, with patience. They should have mercy on
people, be kind to them, and have mercy on the Salafi, may
God have mercy on him." He used to say, "We should try to
keep them in the
Salafi ranks unless we are overwhelmed." He said, "
We should try to keep them in the Salafi ranks unless we are overwhelmed.
If they fall, we will do what we can." He said, "They are responsible." He said, "
That is why we were patient with so-and-so for years, and with so-and-so for
years, and with another for years."
He said, "I do not want the Salafis to scatter and disperse."
His examples of patience with those who disagree are numerous. He was patient with
Abdul Rahman Abdul Khaliq for many years, hoping he would
return and repent. He sent him messages until
Abdul Rahman Abdul Khaliq became obstinate and arrogant. He was
patient with Salman.  Returning to what was criticized in this
hadith, he responded to it, or wrote a book in response
and sent it to him for a whole year, hoping that Salman would return to the
hadith of
God Almighty. He
patiently wrote a response to Safar al-Hawali and sent it to
him, hoping that he would repent or return. He used to
say, "Perhaps..." And let the esteemed reader know that in his
response to Safar, I sent him
this discussion to protect him, hoping that he would
return and correct what he had done.
But unfortunately, he did not respond to us despite waiting for a
long time. He was a grandson, and it would have been more appropriate for
him to rejoice in this advice.
Likewise, he was very patient with Abu al-Hasan al-Murabbi, advising
him a great deal. He respected and appreciated him and advised him gently and kindly. He was very patient with
Adnan Ar'ur and Ali al-
Halabi as well,
advising them and sending them advice for many years. The same applies to al-Maghrawi and others, including Adnan Ar'ur al-Halabi. And yet,
this famous person comes along and says that he was hasty
in responding to al-Maghrawi, Ar'ur, Ali Hassan, and
others, including Abu al-Hasan al-Halabi.
Among his statements
about
Abu al-Hasan al-Murabbi is, "Our sheikh who started the
war..."  For years, I have been advising him, both orally and in writing, to
extinguish the flames of his sedition. He has been asking
questions about him, so I advise those asking to refrain
from asking and to stop gossiping.
But he is a source of sedition, a rebellion against the
Salafi methodology, its scholars, and its students, and
other such things. Among the great and noble qualities of the Sheikh, may
God have mercy on him, was his immense generosity and
his keenness for Salafism everywhere. His generosity, his giving, his munificence,
his assistance to the needy and the poor,
and his helping Salafis everywhere are all things that can be said
about him. There is no harm in mentioning some of
the things that only a few people know: the
Sheikh
owns a gas station in
the south with shops that are rented out, and
all the money he makes is dedicated to the Salafi Sheikh Rabi', may God have mercy on him.
As for his worship,
his weeping, his remembrance of God, and his recitation of the
Quran, I
knew this from my close association with him. He was always keen on performing the
night prayer,
listening to the Quran as soon as he woke up in the
morning.
As for the remembrance of God, the Almighty, it was always on his tongue.  Glory be to Him, the Most High.
Our Sheikh, Sheikh Rabi, may God have mercy on him, had
many writings, which were compiled in the collections of Sheikh
Rabi, may God have mercy
on him. He was praised by his contemporaries, his brothers and sheikhs.
I mentioned in this regard the praise of his sheikh, Ubaydullah al-
Rahman Mubarak, may God have mercy
on him. His sheikh, His Eminence Sheikh Abdul Aziz
bin Baz, may
God have mercy on him, also praised him. Sheikh Rabi said, "He is among the best of the
Ahlus Sunnah wal Jama'ah." He used to tell him, "
Respond to everyone who makes a mistake.
If Ibn Baz makes a mistake, respond to him. If
Ibn Ibrahim makes a mistake, respond to him."
I heard this with my own ears from His Eminence Sheikh Abdul Aziz bin
Baz.
Sheikh Rabi bin Baz, may God have mercy on him, even sent him letters asking him to respond to so-and-so
who had made a mistake. May
God have mercy on him.
Also among that is the praise of Sheikh Muhammad
Nasir ad-Din al-Albani,
Sheikh al-Albani.
He said regarding those who criticize the Sheikh, "They are either a companion or
ignorant." He knows the
meaning of Sheikh Ibn Baz's praise,
as well as the praise of Sheikh Salih al-Fawzan. Sheikh Salih
also loved Sheikh Salih al-Fawzan very much.
Sheikh Salih al-Fawzan
and Sheikh  Al-Luhaidan, Sheikh Muqbil, our Sheikh, Sheikh
Ubaid, and other Sunni scholars,
Sheikh Muqbil, Sheikh Ubaid, and
also our Sheikh, Sheikh Ahmad Al-Najmi, may God have mercy on him,
loved Sheikh Rabi' very much.
Ahmad Al-Najmi, may God have mercy on him, was
once asked about those who criticize Sheikh Rabi', and
he said, "This indicates that he has ulterior motives, that he is an
innovator, and that he is an aide to innovators." There are
many other praises from scholars for our Sheikh.
We ask God Almighty to forgive him and grant him
spacious gardens in Paradise.
This is a brief overview and biography of our Sheikh, highlighting his
scholarly and da'wah status. And
God knows best. May God's peace and blessings be upon our Prophet
Muhammad, and upon his family and
companions. May God reward you.